hey wordsmiths just checking in you
doing okay the word we're talking about
today is alienated
alienated it's an adjective and it means
feeling excluded and apart from other
people kind of a bummer word but at the
same time a fascinating one I can hear
the question I imagine some of you are
asking David does this have anything to
do with aliens like from outer space and
the answer is well kind of it's all the
same word follow me earthlings to the
derivation station let's talk about this
word's Origins did it come from outer
[Music]
space no it comes from Latin alos or All
in Latin means different other something
that is alien is different strange new
and foreign an alien is someone from
another country or in more modern
language a being from another planet and
then 8 at is a verb forming suffix it
turns nouns and adjectives into action
words this robot is not active I will
activate it someone needs to assign a
value to this artwork I will evaluate it
right a very powerful suffix so let's
put this knowledge to work what are some
words you can think of that contain that
Al root that root that means other or
at8 the verb forming suffix
okay here we go people of Earth 10c
music
[Music]
break here are some words that I came up
with altruism which means caring about
other people doing work for the sake of
others an alias a word that means an
assumed name another name uh and
Captivate to capture someone's
imagination or attention to Fascinate to
charm when you feel alienated you feel
like a stranger in your own country like
all the clocks are running backwards and
the world is just wrong I don't know why
I'm trying to explain this to you
wordsmiths nobody understands the
feeling of alienation better than the
young alone in a crowd is the vibe
basically let's use alienated in some
sentences shall we the Galactic tourist
felt alienated by the strange food
stuffs of this curious new planet oh no
the alien feels homesick and sad when
they try to eat pizza they don't know
how to do it here's one that hits a
little bit closer to home Noemi didn't
get cast in the play and it left her
feeling alienated from her friends who
did there they are in the background all
crowded around the cast list an awful
feeling all your friends have something
to do together after school and you
can't be a part of it because you're not
in the play
I I certainly don't know what that's
like Anyway another word for alienation
is
estrangement the feeling of being made
strange being made to feel far
away may you never feel that feeling
wordsmiths or if you do may you never
feel it for long you can learn anything
David out